welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Mark Turan an associate research
scientist at Yale University and
director of the digital Himalaya project
and world or a literature project
professor Turin is an anthropologist and
a linguist his scholarly focus is on the
Himalayan region in particular Nepal
northern India Bhutan and cultural tibet
professor tyrrans research interests
include the documentation of endangered
languages and mapping global cultural
diversity language policy and the role
of native tongue instruction in
education and issues relating to the
electronic access and ownership of
anthropological materials from
ethnographic museums today we talk with
him about his involvement in the world
or a literature project welcome
professor turn I'm delighted to be here
let's begin with an overview of your
project tell us about it the project was
established in January 2009 based at the
University of Cambridge where I work as
a partnership between anthropologists
linguists community members and people
involved in collections archivists and
librarians and people in museums as an
urgent global initiative to come
together and work to preserve protect
document and then disseminate these
incredibly diverse forms of oral
tradition oral literature that exist
around the world how did you become
involved well I've been working in the
Himalayas for almost 20 years now from
1991 onwards and as an anthropologist
and a linguist I've been working
particularly with two ethnic groups and
their languages Nepal is a country of 27
million people but home to about 106
languages incredible linguistic
diversity from four different language
families in fact the Himalayan belt is
really a kind of mega center of
diversity in all senses ecological
environmental culture
linguistic so my own work has been
predicated really on a deep
understanding and appreciation of the
linguistic forms that that make people
who they are and give them a kind of
cultural attachment their own identity I
should add that of the world 6500
languages probably up to half are
endangered Wow and most of those
languages themselves are also oral
primarily transmitted orally so we have
to think about most of the world's
linguistic and cultural diversity being
transmitted by word of mouth and what
are the goals of the project the project
is doing a number of things to support
both communities and also careful
documentation projects I like to use the
words collect protect and connect to
describe a little bit what we do
collection is not the acquisition in a
kind of colonial or acquisitive manner
of materials but rather the careful
partnering with people who have
collections of oral literature of
cultural traditions epic poetry songs
myths whether they be on hard disk on
tape recorder and thinking about how
those collections might best be
preserved protected so that they will
also be able to transmit to the next
generation and then also to disseminate
those when appropriate online in print
on air so we're building collections on
an offline of these incredible oral
traditions we're also running training
workshops for community members and
scholars to come together to come up
with the best practices about how to
document carefully we run a publications
program occasional papers that we print
as well as a partnership now with a
cambridge-based publisher the open book
publishers to try and disseminate
materials like this online and also we
give out grants have the most important
thing we do is get out small grants
stimulus grants seed corn money to
particularly community members involved
in documentation projects we've given
out 18 grants now and we have
collections from 30 different countries
on our website let's talk a little bit
about the work you are doing to capture
these oral cultures and then I'd also
like to talk a little bit about some
cultures that perhaps have been lost
forever so do you actually send people
out into the world to try and collect
this information partly and then also I
guess it's communities coming to you
looking for money to help documents that
the oral cultures as well that's quite
right I don't believe that it's a good
model to send people out from the West
you need to go and collect documents i
think the partnerships what we're trying
to support there are lots of grants out
there for university-based scholars in
the US the UK and europe to apply for
money for fieldwork we're interested in
the people who fall through those gaps
they can't apply that state of the
national science foundation or the
British Academy because they don't
adhere or they're not part of any
National University in their own home
country we believe that is the elegant
partnerships that we can support by
which may be foreign scholars are
working deeply in association with the
community the community want to do
something they have a cultural center
there is a local oral knowledge holder
who may be eager to share their
knowledge and have it documented and
that triangulation of research between
maybe a foreign scholar who provides
support training resources a local
community who are actively engaged and
also people in the field who have the
knowledge they want to share that's not
what time is all right excellent that's
can you give us a specific example of
something recently that you've worked on
we've worked a lot in Asia in India and
Nepal and also cultural Tibetan parts of
China partly because many of the board
members of the project have research
areas and interests there so we've
supported a project in central India
whereby a community member wanted to do
work didn't have the technology
themselves to to actually do careful
documentation got some training through
our project got a small grant and is
working with a local anthropologist and
they are collecting amazing stories
about a performance of sort of snake
worship that lasts all night long and
they have been committing that material
to our website also publishing through
us so it's a kind of stimulus grant to
support people who are doing great work
who otherwise might not get the access
okay and let's be clear by oral culture
what do you mean by that okay well
that's a very nice question in a way and
let's make it more complex by saying
oral literature it's a difficult term it
doesn't trip off the tongue but also
it's a term that setting do for some
rehabilitation we have to realize that
most of the work
world's cultures how are transmitted
orally and languages are not just about
words and grammar but they're about the
vehicles for the transmission of
cultural knowledge oral literature and
oral culture encompass all those forms
of verbal art that if you don't have a
writing system if you don't have a
traditionally developed writing system
perhaps where you would commit your
knowledge and your history to paper then
it's all encoded orally so songs poetry
proverbs trickster rhymes epic poetry
and all kinds of genres of oral
performance and those things can relate
to the environment to agriculture to
history and knowledge I've worked very
closely with shaman's in the Himalayas
in Nepal in particular who really are
the repositories of all knowledge about
the community but also about the past so
how do you capture that information do
you videotape it you record it all of
the above one of the most exciting
things that's happening i think is the
revolution in access to Internet
technology and generally digital
technology on the one hand of course
globalization and whatever that may be
maybe one of the processes that is
eroding the diversity of human cultural
expressions around the world we think
all the time about people on the fringes
on the margins being sort of pushed to
the sides further at the same time
fairly cheap air travel a better
communications through Skype and email
and Internet mean that people have
access for the first time to quite
affordable digital technology one of the
things that we've seen communities
interested in is not having to commit
their oral knowledge to print which can
somehow lock it down into one genre and
perhaps even ossify it and make it
difficult to transmit again so digital
technology videos you say an audio
recording is a very important part of
what we're doing it allows three or four
different performances to live in
parallel and not one of them to be
committed as standard okay are there
oral cultures today that are endangered
of of going away forever and once they
do go away is it possible to bring them
back somehow many of the world's oral
cultures and the languages that convey
them are endangered and at risk
whether it's possible to bring them back
is a much more complex question I'm
sorry let me interrupt and they're
endangered because the people are dying
off and and why are they indeed there
are magnets for languages to be
endangered and then the cultures that
are associated with them most languages
become endangered because the speaker's
themselves transition to speaking
another language they move out of their
tribal or regional or ethnic language
into the maybe more a national or
international language another thing
that does happen is the communities
themselves can be completely wiped out
whether it be through war famine
migration or natural disasters and we
saw that during the tsunami when small
communities were completely destroyed at
the same time sometimes languages can
bounce back there's a wonderful story
actually of a project in the u.s.
working in Oklahoma with the Miami tribe
who have kind of reclaimed and
revitalized language that probably was
on the cusp of disappearance I don't
believe that it's for scholars to revive
languages or save them that's not really
a term that we should use it is however
communities who save languages and
support their own transmission and
scholars can partner with them and work
with them to make sure those stories
succeed there are all the time stories
of languages and cultures disappearing
without record vanishing voices last
year their language ball which is spoken
on the Andaman Islands disappeared when
the last speaker died there's a language
in nepal by the name of couse under
which may have a couple of speakers left
but essentially transmission where you
still have children who speak it has
completely ceased so those languages
really are on their last legs and have
has the project done any work with those
two examples in fact not those two
languages but we are supporting a
scholar senior Indian academic who's
coming to give a lecture about one of
those languages she's worked for the
last 20 years in that community what are
some of the greatest challenges that the
project phases there are many challenges
there are logistical challenges in terms
of deploying our resources and our
knowledge appropriately in the field
many of the places that we work our
places of political turmoil and strife
they can be very remote two or three
days walk from a road so communications
can be difficult I think and other
challenges
really telling the story to an audience
of people who are interested I'm always
surprised by how many people react to
the story of endangered languages a kind
of neo-darwinian logic oh well if people
aren't using them just let them die is
often invoked but those very same people
who are against the documentation of
let's say endangered culture endangered
language are interested in their local
church an old building they want to
restore that they may be very concerned
by global biodiversity and some of the
endangered species that we know about on
the planet so I think we have a mission
really to connect with the wider
audience of practice often outside of
the universities as much as inside
people who are committed to this kind of
work need the support and have unique
collections they want to share why is it
important that we not let these
languages die off why should we care I
mean to your point I grew up
multilingual my mother is Dutch and my
father was Italian so I grew up already
speaking a number of languages I think
multilingualism has been the norm for
most of the world over most of history
and monolingualism namely speaking one
language and increasingly that's
something like English let's say is a
historical aberration it hasn't been the
case for most people over most of
history that they speak one soul
language I believe that making sense of
understanding and appreciating our
cultural and linguistic diversity is
part of what makes us human in fact some
people would argue that language the
potential for language and our ability
to speak at children learn it without
even trying is one of the defining
features of our humanity one of my
colleagues said that it would be an
absolute disaster if linguistics went
down as one of the only disciplines in
science to preside over the demise of
its own subject matter and do nothing we
have to act very good thank you so much
for being here with us today and sharing
some of your work it's a real pleasure
thank you for more information about
professor turin and his research please
visit our website at yale edu backslash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you